One of the first lessons
that they teach you,
are giving you small, very simple mission
in which you pretend to be someone else.
I was in the street and my instructor
showed me a passing taxi,
told me, "See the number of the taxi?"
I said, "Yes."
Said, "Okay, taxi disappeared."
And he told me, "In two hours, you meet me
at this and this corner and you bring me
the name and the address
of the taxi driver."
And of course I could
not use the internet,
of course no police, no official office,
because I was supposed
to pretend I'm a tourist.
And I felt, what will I, what should I do?
So I started to go from one
taxi station to the other,
asking people if they
know this and this car
with this or this number.
And because I forgot something,
it is very important that
I find this taxi driver
because I forgot something in his car.
So they start calling
each other, finding out.
And then there was another helpful guy
who was willing to take me to the house
of this taxi driver, which he did.
And I fulfilled my mission.
I was the only one from the people
who were in training with me,
who brought the information back.
When you want to recruit someone
for an undercover mission,
you're looking for certain traits.
First of all, is the ability to play act
and to impersonate someone else.
If you don't have that,
then all the rest is
immaterial after that.
And if you have to work
undercover in an enemy country,
your cover has to be perfect.
When people suspect you,
it can become very unpleasant
and very dangerous.
And you have to have an
identity of a real person,
a person that is living somewhere
with a real name with real history.
And this is the life that you learn,
you pretend to be that person.
And then, of course, you
add some other things
and other traits because
it has to suit you.
So you go to the place where this person
is supposed to live, you learn the area,
you live there for a while.
You take a room in a hotel, let's say,
and everyday you walk to a different place
until you feel that you
know the area very well,
because this person is supposed
to have been raised there.
So you learn as much as possible.
And when you don't know the
detail, you find in the area,
a detail that is good enough for it.
For instance, you don't
know exactly the school
they went to, but there
is a school in the area.
So this is the school that you mention
when you are being asked.
You really have to believe
that you are this other person.
One very important thing to
act while being interrogated,
is never be aggressive,
never be conceited,
never show that you are
too sure of yourself.
Be humble, be nice, be
friendly, be naive even,
pretend to not understand too much.
And act natural towards the situations
as if it was something completely natural
that everybody else is going through.
And if he starts to like
you because you're nice
and maybe if you make him
feel even sorry for you,
that you're maybe a bit
scared or frightened,
and then he's on your side.
He does not want to break you.
You have to really, to act very carefully.
So it's not to bring him to a place
where he wants to show you,
who is the stronger of the two.
Whenever you go into a place,
into a store or something,
you are all the time
watching for escape routes,
just in case.
It becomes part of your nature.
Like noticing people around you,
noticing who's watching
you, who's talking to you.
You just, you're more alert
than people usually are.
If worst comes to worst,
you have an escape plan.
Of course, you have a set of clothes
that are completely different,
you change your appearance,
you change your papers,
and you take a car and
you cross the border.
Or you have an aircraft
coming to rescue you,
or you go out to sea and
wait for it to being rescued.
Or you are helped by
another agency in the area
who smuggle you out of the country.
There are many different ways to do that.
You're always prepared
to grab your things,
the bare necessities
that you need for this
and just disappear from the area.